und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und annegellinek
guten Abend
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann hat
ein ruhiges sommer-wochenende ausgesucht
um nichts weniger als eine Zitat
Buschmann zeitenwände im Familienrecht
anzustoßen die Regelungen zur Zahlung
von Unterhalt sein hoffnungslos veraltet
bei einer Scheidung mit minderjährigen
Kindern gelte aus rechtlicher Sicht fast
immer eine betreut einer zahlt die
Realität sei aber dass immer mehr Eltern
auch nach einer Trennung die
Kinderbetreuung untereinander aufteilten
deshalb müsse auch der Unterhalt fairer
geregelt werden ob das zu mehr
Gerechtigkeit führen kann er Gründen
mattis Feldhoff und Henriette de
Maizière
es ist ein Thema mit Streitpotenzial für
die gesamte Koalition ein Thema bei dem
die politischen Protagonisten voller
Emotionen sind ein Thema bei dem die
Begriffe Gerechtigkeit und Fairness
völlig unterschiedlich gesehen werden
können
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann will
jetzt mehr Fairness sagt er will dass
sich die Betreuungsleistung in der
Unterhaltspflicht widerspiegelt so wie
im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und es
macht nach dem jetzigen Unterhaltsrecht
keinen Unterschied für die
Unterhaltspflicht ob beispielsweise der
weniger betreuende Elternteil sich an
einem oder an drei Tagen in der Woche um
das Kind kümmert und das ist natürlich
unfair aber was ist gerecht was ist
gerechtfertigt wo beginnt die
Ungerechtigkeit Buschmann rechnet in
einem Beispiel seine Idee vor ein Vater
der 4000 € nette verdient und sein Kind
zu 40% betreut sowie eine Mutter die nur
2000 € hat aber 60% der Betreuung
leistet
derzeit zahlt der Vater mehr als 500 €
bei Anrechnung der Erziehungsleistung
könnte er rund 100 € Rabatt bekommen die
Familienministerin nimmt sich heute am
Tag der offenen Tür der Bundesregierung
zurück der ampelzoff der letzten Woche
scheint nachzuwirken und sie kennt das
Papier des Ministerkollegen noch nicht
von daher freue ich mich dass die
Eckpunkte jetzt vorliegen bin ganz
sicher dass wir auch in der nächsten
Woche dann bekommen werden und es dann
genau ein Bild machen können um
gemeinsam als Koalition dann diese
Reform auf den Weg zu bringen die
betroffenen Verbände befürchten dagegen
schon heute dass der Kern dieser Reform
nichts mit Fairness zu tun hat wir
finden das überhaupt nicht fair schon
jetzt ist ja jedes zweite Kind von in
einer ein elternfamilie von Armut
betroffen wenn jetzt noch weniger
Unterhalt reinkommt dann ist das
wirklich sehr unfair für die Kinder und
nicht nur die Verbände bezweifeln dass
weniger Unterhalt durch mehr Arbeit
ausgeglichen werden kann
diese Auswirkung die der Herr Buschmann
jetzt kommen sieht setzt natürlich auch
voraus dass es flexible Berufe gibt also
Berufe wo ich in der Zeit wo unser Kind
bei mir ist weniger arbeite um dafür in
der anderen Seite entsprechend mehr zu
arbeiten noch gibt es keinen
Referentenentwurf keine Abstimmung in
der Regierung keinen Gesetzestext doch
die Skepsis zu den Vorschlägen des
Justizministers ist schon laut
vernehmbar
sein Name steht noch auf den
Stimmzetteln Fernando will ja visencio
war einer der aussichtsreichsten
Kandidaten für die morgige
Präsidentschaftswahl in Ecuador bis er
vor zehn Tagen brutal erschossen wurde
der Ermordete hatte angekündigt
entschieden gegen die organisierte
Kriminalität vorgehen zu wollen die hat
Ecuador das einst zu den sichersten
Ländern in Lateinamerika gehörte fest im
Griff
strategisch gelegen zwischen den beiden
großen
kokainproduzenten Kolumbien und Peru
liefern sich drogenkatelle und Mafia
Banden erbitterte Kämpfe um die
Vorherrschaft über einen Wahlkampf in
schusssicheren Westen berichtet
Christoph röckerath
erlöse uns von dem Bösen das Vaterunser
ersetzt die Wahlkampfparolen eigentlich
hätte hier Fernando via visencio seine
Abschlusskundgebung halten sollen einer
von acht Kandidaten für das Amt des
äquatorianischen Präsidenten doch vor
gut einer Woche wurde er ermordet und so
halten nun Angehörige darunter seine
Mutter und politische Weggefährten ein
Trauergottesdienst unter
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen die den Eindruck
noch einmal verstärken das Ecuador eine
Demokratie unter Beschuss ist auch die
meisten Bürger haben Angst nur wenige
wollen vor der Kamera mit uns reden
sehr bedauerlich alles die Lage ist
chaotisch extrem unsicher viel Gewalt
man kann nicht ruhig durch die Straßen
gehen
ich hoffe dass die Leute sich gut
überlegen wem sie ihre Stimme geben denn
die Demokratie ist in Gefahr
[Musik]
wurde nach einer Veranstaltung auf
offener Straße erschossen die
Hintergründe sind unklar doch er hatte
wiederholt Korruption und organisiertes
Verbrechen angeprangert bei der
Trauerfeier entladen sich Wut und
Frustration
jetzt fasst die Polizei auf aber wenn
man sie braucht ist sie nicht da
bis vor wenigen Jahren galt Ecuador als
eines der sichersten Länder Südamerikas
inzwischen aber ist es zu einem der
wichtigsten Drehkreuze des
internationalen Drogenhandels geworden
vor allem von der Hafenstadt guiakiel
aus organisieren die Kartelle den Kokain
schmuggeln nach Europa die Mordrate hat
dramatisch zugenommen auch die Anschläge
auf Politiker der Nachfolger des
ermordeten Präsidentschaftskandidaten
via visenseo bringt es auf den Punkt
wir müssen zugeben dass Ecuador de facto
zu einem Staat der Kartelle geworden ist
noch ist es kein gescheiterter Staat
denn wir haben die Mittel das abzuwenden
doch danach sieht es im Moment eher
nicht aus selbst aus den Gefängnissen
operieren die Kartelle weiter ihren
Aufstieg erklären Experten unter anderem
mit einer verfehlten Sicherheitspolitik
ein grundsätzliches Umdenken müsste her
die Politik verweigert sich der Realität
lieber suchen die Politiker kleine
Vorteile für sich in einer Dynamik links
gegen Rechts anstatt nach einer
ernsthaften Lösung zu suchen für dieses
Problem das täglich Menschenleben kostet
innere Sicherheit ist nun das Top-Thema
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl am morgigen
Sonntag
[Applaus]
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und da schauen wir zunächst
in die Ukraine Gundula von dort kommen
heute wieder Meldungen über getötete
Zivilisten
in cernyhilf nördlich von Kiew sind
mindestens sieben Menschen ums Leben
gekommen unter den fast 100 Verletzten
sollen 15 Kinder sein russische Raketen
schlugen im Stadtzentrum ein
beschädigten auch ein Theater vor dem
Angriff hatte russlands Präsident Putin
in Roßdorf mit generellen gesprochen die
für die russische Offensive zuständig
sind bei seinem Besuch in Schweden
verurteilte der ukrainische Präsident
selenski den Angriff auf Jeremy und bat
um weitere militärische Hilfe
internationale Kritik gibt es an einer
Attacke auf UN-Soldaten auf Zypern dort
hatten türkische
zypre-sicherheitskräfte der Vereinten
Nationen angegriffen und mehrere schwer
verletzt
die unverwalten eine Pufferzone zwischen
dem türkischen Norden und dem
griechischen Süden der Mittelmeerinsel
die türkischen hatten dort eine Straße
bauen wollen ohne Genehmigung deswegen
blockierten die un-angehörigen die
Baustelle und wurden attackiert
bei einem mutmaßlich palästinensischen
Anschlag im Westjordanland sind zwei
israelische Zivilisten getötet worden
das Militär hat Straßensperren errichtet
und fahndet nach den Tätern sie sollen
die Israelis Vater und Sohn mit
Schusswaffen angegriffen haben die
Gewalt in Israel und in Westjordanland
hat seit Jahresbeginn wieder stark
zugenommen
in Kanada lodern mehr als 1000
Waldbrände die Provinz British Columbia
am Pazifik rief den Notstand aus der
Flächenbrand rund um die Stadt kilona
hatte sich in den letzten 24 Stunden
Rasen schnell ausgebreitet auch im
Nordwesten Kanadas brennt es dort musste
die Stadt yellow knife evakuiert werden
wir konnten nicht sehen wir fuhren durch
glühende Asche beschreibt eine Frau ihre
Flucht vor dem Feuer im Auto über den
Highway Claudia Bates berichtet
während er in seliger Ahnungslosigkeit
sein morgen Bad genießt sehen die
Menschen das riesige Unheil dass hier
unerbittlich auf sie zukommt die Feuer
bei kilona sind nicht unter Kontrolle
Hausbesitzer lehnen sich auf gegen das
Unvermeidliche schlagen im beißenden
Rauch Feuer Schneisen und bewässern die
Grundstücke um ihre Häuser zu schützen
doch zahlreiche Gebäude sind bereits
niedergebrannt
das Feuer breitet sich rasend schnell
aus seine Fläche hat sich innerhalb
eines Tages verzehnfacht
wir stellen sicher dass wir da sind und
uns um die Bedürfnisse der Gemeinden
kümmern und wir werden hier sein in den
kommenden Monaten und Jahren um dafür zu
sorgen dass Menschen in Sicherheit sind
wir werden wieder aufbauen da wo wir
schreckliche Verluste beklagen müssen
auch im Norden Kanadas in yellow knife
kämpft die Feuerwehr gegen den
übermächtigen Feind die gesamte
Bevölkerung hier wurde aufgefordert die
Gegend zu verlassen sich in Sicherheit
zu bringen fast alle der 20.000
Einwohner von Yellow knife haben ihr zu
Hause verlassen
es hat mir schon einen Schrecken
eingejagt wenn man das hier sieht
ehrlich dann will ich hier weg
Kanada erlebt die verheerendste
Waldbrandsaison seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen in einigen Provinzen ist
nach Angaben der Regierung die
Durchschnittstemperatur in den letzten
75 Jahren um fast zwei Grad gestiegen
experten rechnen deshalb mit zunehmen
zerstörerischen Bränden
es ist ein Sommer der extreme brennenden
brennende Wälder auf der ganzen Welt und
Korallen denen es im Meer zu warm wird
im drittgrößten Korallenriff der Erde
vor der Küste Floridas sind
Naturschützer schon länger dazu
übergegangen Korallen an kleinen
Gerüsten auf dem Meeresboden künstlich
großzuziehen Ziel ist sie später in die
Riffe zurück zu pflanzen nun da das Meer
mit über 30 Grad zu warm geworden ist
haben sich die Naturschützer etwas Neues
ausdenken müssen eine Art Hitzefrei für
Korallen der wird sauer zeigt David
sauer zeigt wie es funktionieren könnte
Ausfahrt zu den paradiesischen
Tauchgründen ganz im Süden Floridas
Bailey Thomsen und ihr Team steuern die
Korallenriffe der Kies an die sind hier
die unter Wasser Attraktion und das
Rückgrat des Ökosystems aber sie könnten
sterben diese Leute wollen das
verhindern
ist die Temperatur verheerend das ist so
ähnlich wie bei uns wenn wir Fieber
haben geht es uns ja auch nicht gut
mehr als 32 Grad hat das Wasser derzeit
zu viel und das so früh im Jahr lange
überleben die empfindlichen Korallen das
nicht
Tauchgang zur unterwassergärtnerei in
zwölf Metern Tiefe mit feinem Werkzeug
sammeln Bailey und ihr Team die Korallen
ein
zusammen mit Fischen Algen und Krebsen
bilden Sie hier einen Kreislauf des
Lebens alles hängt miteinander zusammen
die Bedeutung von Korallenriffen ist
astronomisch sie sind essentiell für das
Ökosystem im Meer die Menschen sollten
sich darum kümmern und Riffe bieten
außerdem Küstenschutz wenn Hurricanes
durchziehen Schwächen sie die
Sturmfluten ab
1.500 Korallenstücke sammeln Sie dieses
mal vorsichtig ein und bringen sie an
Land bevor sie ausgleichen und Sterben
der Niedergang der Riffe beschleunigt
sich seit Jahren und geht aktuell
schneller als die Retter hinterherkommen
die Situation sei dramatisch
wir verlieren im nächsten halben
Jahrhundert die Risse wenn wir nicht
handeln ein ganzes Ökosystem das gab es
noch nie in der Geschichte der
Menschheit
um das zu verhindern oder zumindest zu
bremsen bringen sie die gesammelten
Korallen an Land dort werden sie über
Monate aufgepäppelt in kühlerem
nährstoffreichen Wasser darin sollen sie
wachsen und gesund werden um sie später
wieder auszusetzen
wir sehen dass hier wie so eine Art
Triage als wären wir ein Krankenhaus
wenn die Korallen ein wenig wachsen
können ist das großartig aber im Moment
würden wir uns schon freuen wenn Sie die
nächsten Monate gesund bleiben
Korallenriffe sind auf den Florida Keys
ein wichtiger Wirtschaftsfaktor und
bringen jährlich rund 2 Milliarden
Dollar ein mehr als 70.000 Arbeitsplätze
hängen davon ab
das ist das drittgrößte Riff der Welt
unser Lebenselixier ohne das was das mit
unserem Geschäft ich will nicht dass
Menschen hier tauchen kommen nur um das
Riff noch ein letztes Mal zu sehen
aktuell erwärmt sich das Meer vor
Florida jeden Tag weiter und es ist erst
Mitte August der Sommer ist noch nicht
vorbei hoch Saison für die
korallenritter
Hitze in Florida und bei uns das Wetter
wird morgen vor allem in der Südhälfte
wieder schwül heißt und sonst sommerlich
sonnig Teilzeit teils wolkig im Osten
sowie im Bergland örtlich Schauer oder
Gewitter 23 Grad an der Nordsee bis 35
Grad am Oberrhein auch in der neuen
Woche hochsommerlich mit viel Sonne und
nur einzelnen Gewittern dabei vor allem
im Süden sehr heiß 23 bis 35 Grad
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto
sie lauten ohne Gewähr 10 17 22 31 36 37
Superzahl 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-556
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
Sportstudio und Jochen Breyer und
natürlich endlich wieder mit der
Fußball-Bundesliga direkt danach gibt's
hier wieder eine heute Express wir sagen
tschüss und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
schönen Sonntag
[Musik]